il a faim que faut-il retenir de cette
brève allocution du ministre de
l'intérieur alors plusieurs annonces
dans cette allocution d'un peu moins de
15 minutes du ministre de l'intérieur
qui a tenu à insister une nouvelle fois
sur le fait que la meilleure façon de
lutter contre la propagation de ce virus
était tout simplement de rester chez soi
il a invité chacun et chacune à
respecter des règles simples se rendre
sur son lieu de travail
faire ses courses et rentrer chez soi il
a tenu à rappeler que si ces règles
n'étaient pas respectées elle serait
sanctionné pas des sanctions pour le
simple le simple fait pardon de
sanctionner mais pour bien protéger la
population je propose de l'écouter
la meilleure façon de combattre le coc
vite 19
c'est de rester chez soi c'est de ne pas
chercher à exploiter à utiliser les
différentes dérogation exceptionnelle
qui sont prévues sur les déplacements
j'invite chacune et chacun à appliquer
une règle simple se rendre de son
domicile sur son lieu de travail puis
après on a fait quelques courses rentrer
chez soi rester chez soi il est
essentiel que ces règles soient
respectées
ce que nous constatons c'est que les
dérogations nécessaires utiles pour la
vie des français sont exploités détourné
par quelques-uns et qu'au moment où je
vous parle chacun en tête ce qui même en
faisant une déclaration cherche à ruser
cherche au fond à faire les malins pour
se croire des héros parce qu'ils
auraient détourné la règle je voudrais
que les choses soient claires il ne
s'agit pas pour nous de sanctionner mais
il s'agit de protéger protéger aussi
ceux qui ont ces comportement anormal et
donc s'il n'a pas été question ce matin
de durcir les mesures qui sont mises en
oeuvre parce que nous les savons
difficile il était décidé que leur mise
en oeuvre serait appliquée de façon plus
stricte encore ainsi par exemple dans
les gares pour le départ au week-end il
sera rappelé et seront sanctionnés tous
les comportements parce que il n'ya pas
de dérogation pour partir en week-end
le combat que nous menons implique
justement d'éviter de se déplacer
implique justement si l'on est infecté
et qu'on ne le sait pas de déplacer le
virus
un peu partout en france nous avons
donné des instructions très claires pour
que des contrôles soient faits dans
toutes les gares dans tous les aéroports
et pour que les déplacements qui sont
possibles le soin que dans le cadre des
autorisations nécessaires pas dans le
cadre des loisirs
alors christophe castaner a également
s'est beaucoup appuyé sur les mers il
compte sur les mers pour lutter contre
la propagation de ce virus il les a
appelés à utiliser leurs pouvoirs de
police pour interdire notamment les
promenades sur les plages et les forces
de sécurité intérieure ne relâcheront
rien ce sont les mots du ministre de
l'intérieur et enfin il a déclaré que
concernant une éventuelle prolongation
de la période de confinement le conseil
de sécurité de défense n'avait rien acté
pour le moment est peut-être une
information qui pourrait intéresser un
aux téléspectateurs christophe castaner
a annoncé qu'il allait répondre aux
questions des français ce soir à 20h30
via un live sur facebook
merci la faam ouzou en direct donc de la
place beauvau à paris